did i hear something
i'm going to carry on if you want to ask
questions i just shout out
um
i hope you've enjoyed your lunch dinner
afternoon tea breakfast or
bedtime snacks during the break
um
but first
just a very quick intro about myself i'm
a software developer from
auckland new zealand
and i work at a great place called xero
the beautiful accounting software
throughout the talk i would love if you
could ask me questions
if you do just call me hack or
you know hux
that's how my friends call me so don't
be shy
today i want to talk to you about
regular expressions and pauses parsers
however before we get into it i must
confess that the title of the talk is uh
inaccurate
for dramatic effects
to be more accurate i think it should be
called less puzzle and less regex more
positive or
try out parsers
when red x fails you
but hopefully you get the idea
so is it regex or regex
if you're a fan of trivia this could be
something to spend a few days of your
life debating
um unfortunately today is not the day
sorry
and because english is not my first
language i'm going to be very liberal
about it i'm going to use both
pronunciations throughout so
hopefully you don't give me trouble for
doing that
there are quite a few good quotes about
regular expressions and my favorite is
this one
some people when confronted with a
problem think
i know i use regular expressions
now they have two problems
this is by jamie zawanski
uh kind of a ton in chief it went um
well like many similar quotes
um you know we may like it or hate it
but we know there is a certain amount of
truth to it and to me the bit of truth
here is that
regular expressions are nice and sweet
but
they can be troublesome if overused
like candy or
perfume
um just to generalize a little bit uh
i'm a big believer
of less is more um when it comes to
programming i believe less code is uh
better than more code
there are somehow
a couple of
exceptions
and the very first one um you guessed it
it's trial expressions have you um ever
have to use it
is it pure joy to use isn't it um i mean
anything to do with the scheduling
and it also must be amongst the most
succinct syntax out there
i actually don't know anything else that
comes even close to chrome expressions
um
imagine your big boss asks you um
hack can you explain these numbers to me
and i'll have to you know put a big
smile on my face and say
okay but do you have eight hours
i'm just so grateful that nice people
out there have made you know great tools
such as this one
otherwise i would never be able to
decrypt or encrypt on expressions with
confidence
with that said though i'm kind of okay
with it because
well it's first is used for one specific
purpose secondly
it's quite well understood for those who
use it
and thirdly
it's kind of well explained by tools
like this
um i hope you agree
it's a little bit annoying it sometimes
makes me feel useless
any questions
okay
our dear regular expressions um can be
quite a different story commit look at
this beautiful baby don't you just love
it
um
if you're not using this on production
to verify email addresses you should
really be ashamed yourself okay
but
in all seriousness
who could really understand it um i mean
i'll
give you one day to decode it and you
know
um i couldn't accept the challenge
it's kind of an extreme example to be uh
to be honest but
um compare
regular expressions to chrome um
expressions
so
regular expressions really has no limit
at least not to its length or obscurity
there are also tools on the internet
that helps us
understand they explain um
regexes but
often i found the explanations not much
easier to understand than the regular
expression themselves
just a few fun facts about regular
expressions
it's a regular language which means it's
actually a language of its own
there are also many flavors to it there
is perl there's pcie which stands for
perl compatible regular expression
there's php which stands for php
you have.net java javascript the list
goes on right
as a regular language it has its
limitations um and it's not always a
good idea to push its limitations
regular expressions are wildly popular
sometimes you can't run away from it all
right
and it's occasionally vague
and hard to get right i have to define
occasional it's you know usual
one of the challenges with using regular
expressions um
or actually programming in general is to
get the right balance between
readability and writeability
if that's a word at all
and often when we can't get the balance
we would prefer readability
because we want other people to
understand our code
it's not just for ourselves
obviously
but this is not always easy with regular
expressions we usually get the opposite
it's also a regular source of uh
disagreements if you uh you know program
as a daily job um
between the writer of a regular
expression and the reader regular
expression the writer possibly after
successful after a couple of failed
attempts
they would think oh this regular
expression is glorious
and the reader on the
other side would usually fail
miserably a couple of times
so they would you know would not
appreciate such beauty immediately um
and tell me you've never come across
this i think everybody does um
and you know what let's be clear i don't
think it's the fault of regular
expressions
indeed um it's us software developers i
think we're notorious for
you know abusing things that are nice
and sweet but you know we keep
stretching them
until they break and become so likable
so what are the alternatives um
obviously
when regular expressions are getting
stretched i think parses can be
extremely handy and this is what we're
going to look at today
the agenda of this talk is very simple
um hopefully
we start to the case study which is
about parsing your
first we're going to use regular
expressions for the job
and then we'll follow with using pauses
um
directly without
an introduction and then of course we
will get a proper introduction
after that there will be more case
studies with parsers
the goals hopefully are also clear um
well first we want to share the
understanding where parts can be useful
and secondly we want to have an
understanding
how puzzles work we're actually going to
implement a parser from scratch okay
exciting
for you and nerve-wracking for me a lot
of uh
live coding
um
and then you know we'll cover the
typical use cases for parsers
i hope that sounds right a lot to cover
uh personally i value
clarity and simplicity so if you feel
you know during the course of this talk
that some not clear enough
you must stop me and ask you know hako
can you explain this a bit more
okay
just don't be shy just shout out i think
it will have plenty of time hopefully
without further ado uh we're gonna jump
right into a
about you know parsing a rest some url
i don't want to call it restful because
uh you know people get really um
you know
excited about restful
designs okay
here are the things we want to do um the
task
is to convert a url to a mode
object so the mode object is the green
boxes
and you can see
the urls are kind of you can imagine
therefore managing
books and a library
and you would make http post requests to
the urls to either
create a book edit a book or clone an
existing book you know possibly to
create a new one
and then based on the structure of the
url
we want to extract useful information
and build the mode object
okay it's kind of like reverse
engineering of routing
so i want us to take a few seconds to
digest this
because you know the
a big part of the talk kind of hinges on
it
again it's not clear this is your chance
to unmute and ask me
any question
all good
now i'm going to um you know get to the
nerve wrecking part for myself
i'm going to do a bit of live coding
um
if you can see uh we just do a code here
we're going to be using typescript
we think why typescript um well i think
it's possibly one of the most popular
languages these days and
it's also my personal favorite um
a lot of people who think oh it's just
javascript plus c sharp but uh it's so
much more than that right
you can get you know conditional types
type calculation and you know sort of
crazy stuff and they're officially in
typescript
isn't that you know one of the coolest
things
okay um
so
i'll start to walk you through the code
and then you know there's the part that
i have to write code um and
really have a nervous breakdown but
first of all
um remember the url schema we're gonna
produce a mode thing as a result so a
mode type
it's either a create
type or an edit or clone type and if you
look at the create type
it has a mode which you know has to be
create
for the type edit or clone it has two
modes edit or clone and then it also has
an id
i know some of us might ask
why don't you just do mode with create
edit and clone with three modes and
then id
well
the reason is
the create type can never have an id
editor clone type can never not have an
id okay so this is kind of a bit of a
domain modeling but in the small
i hope that makes sense
now to be um well-behaving software uh
developers uh we you know we don't want
to be cowboy so we actually have a nice
um test suite and test cases for it
so um this would make sense to you but
let's consolidate our understanding of
the schema
you know out of this url i want to
get back this mode
object with create okay
this is the edit
url which has an id and that will be
edit
and then there's this clone
mode hope that makes sense
again questions just shout out i'll stop
and try to explain
there are also negative test cases
where none of these should work and um
they should you know return now
and
there's um this nice uh test um you test
hopefully make sense
but um
if you don't have time to read through
you just have to take my word and
to give us all the confidence
my windows about a
little um
let's run the tests
that's great demoguard is kind so you
can see the positive cases are not
passing because you know there's a job
that's the job for me to do and the
negative cases are passing because well
they're returning now
so the goal of course is to keep the
negative case
passing but we need to make the positive
cases
pass
okay
here comes um you know the novice
part for me
we already have this posit function
which will be called here of course if
you can see the positive function
i'll just drill into it so that you know
i'm not lying
very simply we have a regex expression a
pattern that we will match against the
url if it's successful then we will
extract an id and a clone string if
clone is there we say
well this is a
clone mode with an id otherwise there's
an edit mode with an id otherwise it's a
create mode with an id i hope that's all
very clear
now um
um how do i begin well i think
i'll start with the most simplest one
right um apparently create
doesn't have d so um
i put this here um
and hopefully that should work
yes well who needs parses right um
it works here
um
well can i just stop here and celebrate
but no uh we need to get to edit so how
do we do edit
well apparently it's going to follow
with another slash right and um
we want to capture the numbers so
um
you know that would be utility let me
save and see works
well it works for edit here see but it
doesn't work for create what i do
well i think it's because this this bit
is actually optional right
to match um create so what i'll do
is make this optional
would this work going a bit of trial and
error oh no it fails edit
is too wrong
well i think it's because this pair of
parentheses
actually constructs a capturing group
sorry so i'm gonna say don't capture
this group
yes
oof i'm on a roll
love it
now how do we end up clone i think it's
more or less the same thing so i think
i'll just piggyback on edit and put
another slash there
and it would follow with a clone
string wouldn't it so um would that work
see we're doing tdd i love that
now it fails edit
what am i doing wrong
well i think it's because well this part
would have to be optional no
so i'm gonna make this optional
and put something here
does this look well
still failing i think we have the same
problem here don't we
this should not be capturing
success
high five everyone
um
wow
let's take uh two seconds to celebrate
um
but also let's um yeah i'm so happy but
i think we need a senator check so what
do i do
um
let's put this uh beautiful baby on the
screen um
how do you feel i'm full of cold sweat
but also i love it you know i just made
this beautiful day
i think you know everybody should be
able to understand
unless
if you look away for two seconds like me
and then look back
oh my god i can't understand it anymore
what did i do um
what does it mean with them
um
i can't understand it but
also you know i do hope that my um
whoever reviews my code will be in a
good mood
um this is so cryptic i mean timing is
everything i hope they review my code
friday morning
definitely not uh monday afternoon right
they've been bad mood
um
right we have to move on as i promised
i'm um
we're gonna be hardcore i'm just gonna
go straight into pauses to get you a
taste
and for this demo i'm going to use a
pauses library called
parsimon
why possibly well first of all i
persimmons okay my favorite fruit
there's a joy to use with typescript or
javascript
and from my personal experience it's a
great library it's very well made
well maintained the maintainer uh brian
molk who gave me their blessing
for this talk um
is an extremely helpful person
so i would highly recommend that you try
this out they also have a sister library
called
bread and butter
the naming is just incredible uh you
should totally check that out if you're
interested
with that said um there are excellent
parsers libraries out there for any main
mainstream languages so you will have no
problem finding your favorite okay so
this it's just for a good demo today
without further ado again uh
we're gonna jump right in um
want to go to this up
you know this parses file um before we
do that of course we uh we're going to
reuse the same test suite okay so i'm
going to import the same function from
the parser file
and just to show you that i'm not lying
that all the tests are you know failing
again
and then
pass a
function
well
we have this url parser that's not quite
defined
and um
currently it's returning a empty
mode object so you should be failing all
the
test cases positive test cases excuse me
and if you look at you know just the
first impression how pauses work you run
the password against the url here
if it's successful we return the value
from the result otherwise we return now
okay hopefully that's a very simple
thing
to understand
okay um again the nerve um
wrecking part i'm gonna
create a url parser um live coding oh my
god
i get myself into
um i'm gonna i'm gonna be uh very uh
declarative because i like declarative
programming what do i do um i will start
from top and go to the bottom
um
you know just get a load of the syntax
okay
i think the url parser being our
schema there are three alternatives
there is clone i'll start with the most
specific one along with an id and a
clone string okay
and there is edit and there is create
how does that sound
i hope that's um that makes sense so
that we now do
need to um create the
uh the three parses okay so
clone edit create there actually uh
pauses within pauses okay so
easily i'm gonna create a create parser
well um
if we um
if i remember well the create parser is
simply this
okay it's just this string
with slash book okay
well it's not gonna
make the test run but
i'm gonna go on to create the edit
parser
which will be if i can type
well i think it would be create actually
followed by
a slash
so i'm going to say it's followed by
a slash in this way
and then followed by a book id
and again i'm going to be declaration
i'll just create one
called book id and now of course
mind you i have to create a book id
parser see they're all parsers
so we're getting a load of part with
what is a book id i think is a digit
now the syntax might be a bit foreign
but hopefully
if you calm down you can understand it
it's at least one digit right we don't
want to uh get an empty string
um and then i am going to join all the
digi
together because you know all the keys
will come in as an array so
a bit of javascript
will join the array of digits into
one book id hopefully that makes sense
and we have one last thing to define of
course
the clone parser will be
the edit parser followed by
slash clone right so
i'm going to use another thing called
skip
followed by string of
clone
does that compile
it doesn't of course um because
typescript is going to tell us the types
don't match so
i like the passes created but i do have
to do a mapping
just so that i know
that clone and edit pauses will give me
the id we'll figure that out later if
you think this is confusing but
if i take the id i can create an object
with the id and the mode
the mode will be cloned here
and the same happens to edit
just so that i know that id will be the
result of the edit parser and the mode
here will be
edit
that allows the auto completion
and the create thing it's most simplest
i don't really care about
you know what's the result of the parser
because
you know uh we don't need an id so i am
just easily going to
give it a mode create
yes
it all works
together was on a roll
um now let's take just one
few seconds to look at this
i hope this
declarative way of making a partner
makes sense to you
we're simply
saying
the url
is either create edit or clone and
how are they created they're actually
created iteratively
in terms of each other
okay
any questions at this moment
okay comfortable silence i'm okay with
that
that is just to get us a taste of um
personal and parsers in general okay so
i'm quite sure you have questions if
this is new to you but you know we'll
get to it later
um
so far for our example it would seem
that parsers do about the same thing as
red x
um
and given the context we have i think is
a fair thing to say because they're
solving the same task at this moment
um but even without going further
we can see there are a few differences
well first of all quite obviously
puzzles are more explicit we're writing
more code
but hopefully
they're less cryptic
secondly
if this less obvious
but using parsers kind of require
a different flow
now what i mean by that
with regular expressions usually three
steps
so we match a regex pattern against the
string
if it's successful we extract the
capturing groups
out of the match
and then we build the mode
out of the captures
i've got sometimes you just need to
match right sometimes you don't really
want to build something out of it but
this would be um a pretty general
summary of the workflow
with parsers it's slightly different
as you can see we um
select or skip data conditionally
so the terms value the functions that i
use you know the then function skip
function
they
they conditionally ignore or capture
something and then we build
the mode um object the result on the fly
but piece by piece see we have
ids and then we ignore some data
eventually build the mode
object
and also kind of strange
parsers they're just functions
um
so we must apply the puzzle in the end
to get the result
of course pauses are so much more than
what we just sing but before we go any
further let's make a brief um but more
proper introduction
so what are parsers exactly
well it's you know a good source of
truth uh wikipedia is where i usually go
to
my first attempt
but like many
you know technical terms
pages this is quite dense and um
you know
i try really hard but i think i can pick
out a few keywords here
um for example
parsing
it's kind of equivalent to syntactic
analysis
it's used for natural languages
programming languages
or data structures
it's also
an essential part of making compilers
for
programming languages
i must admit that was a bit overwhelming
the wikipedia page uh luckily there were
great people there who didn't mind you
know darming it down for the likes for
me
um they even made a rhyme for it um
although i never found the tune so
i guess we'll have to improvise um
you know it can be um
jingle bell right like a parser falls
and there's a function from strings
um
yeah i mean i practiced for weeks um
that's the highlight of ndc sydney right
no doubt does anybody want to try a rep
version um
any challenges no
your loss um
[Music]
my version is still the best
um but you know feel free to post your
uh video in this live channel if you do
want to try
if i'm allowed to uh
oversimplify grossly so um oversimplify
it even further a parser is just a
function that turns a string
into a thing
remember the rhyme the parts are all
things i'll keep saying this until you
get so bored um
so it just turns the string
into a thing and it's a function
okay
but how is it done
well puzzles are kind of like uh cute
crocodiles and look at it
um
this cute crocodile would eat the string
part by part
if it likes the part
then it spits out a small thing
if you don't it would stop the whole job
and then it keeps eating it keeps
spitting out more and more small things
on the fly
and then the final big thing it's built
by putting all these small things
together
if
the crocodile you know gets to the end
so why crocodile people say um well it's
because i've seen the video of two all
mates uh bossing a crocodile about have
you seen that video um
you're a nuisance stay put um i never
like uh crocodile cartoons you know i
never thought they're cute
i mean they're gonna kill you right
until i saw this video and then i was
like whoa okay now i got it
they're cute to the aussies
okay enough theory and crocodiles um
let's look at some solid example
um see we have the string that
apparently is an addition right it adds
two numbers together and we want to
pause it
evaluate it
and get the results of the addition
now how is it done with pauses
well actually we're not quite done with
the
cute crocodiles and you know
yeah it's going to be a good meal
digitallicious that's what
uh you can see the crocodile takes uh
four steps to uh
to get to the end
well first of all it eats two digits and
spits out 12
and then it keeps eating and eats the
plus sign
and it's going to spit out a addition
function
called operation
and
thirdly
is going to keep eating and eat the last
two digits and spit out another number
and eventually it's going to apply
the addition operation to the two
numbers
that we get from the result
that's the result
right oh uh more live coding i hope
you're ready for that well actually more
like copy pasting because i don't think
we have um
enough time for me to do that um it's a
slow typist i am
we're going to create this is where we
create a naive
parser from scratch okay
if you're ready i hope you remember you
know 12 plus 34
we want to sew that with a
naive parser that we're going to build
right a daunting task all right we're
going to build something magical from
scratch well first um
we're quite type driven actually so
we're going to start with declaring a
couple of types the result for the
parser which has a value and the rest of
the string remember
it eats it part by part so there would
be the rest
and then we have a parser which is a
function remember it's
a puzzle of things is a function from
the string to results okay
and then we have the symbols
i thought we have another thing which is
just a simple function that
you know either adds or you know
or multiply two numbers together
i hope that makes sense
we're going to list out all the
you know possible digits
very explicit
all the symbol characters
also create a simple helper function
here that converts a symbol to a
function
that either adds
subtracts or multiplies
i hope that makes sense
okay here comes the exciting part
this is how a parser is really built
this is the most basic powder remember
the crocodile is going to eat
a string
part by part but really it does that one
character at a time
the parts is just a function remember
it's rhyme
and if you look at the implementation of
this
this char parser it's very simple right
it says
the raw string it's empty or now
we'll fail immediately otherwise
you want to take the first character and
return and you know keep the rest
does that make sense
questions feel free to ask
we're going to slowly move on to this
strange
parser this is also a parser
called satisfies
and it takes two parameters okay one is
a parser itself we call parser one
there's also a predicate
all it does is to intercept the result
of parser one
and only return the result
if it satisfies the predicate
as you can see the implementation that
does exactly that but there is this
recursive pattern you know if the result
is already null don't do anything just
return on
hope that makes sense
you have to get used to functions within
functions but that's
you know that's what the rhyme tells us
okay there is this mainly parser that
takes one parser
and keeps applying this parser one until
it fails
and puts all the good results before it
fails into an array
you can see there is a bit of recursion
here and it keeps going to next
but you can see the pattern here results
now then
return immediately okay
it keeps adding to the array
many
and then we have a map
function hopefully we're very um
familiar with the concept list
what it does is to take the result of
parser one
and convert it from type t to type u
so it's just like map for a array or a
list
as you can see the implementation does
exactly that
okay
these are actually the fundamental bits
or at least just the bits that we need
now comes the real exciting part we're
going to compose these building blocks
there are only about four or five of
them aren't they
we say digit as a parser
it's just a char parser that satisfies
this condition
that its result is in these characters
you see
makes sense
slowly we're going to move on to the
plural
form of digi
it still satisfies but
this it's saying
digits
is many digit
with at least one digit in it okay
so this would be a
array of string
what's a number parser i hope you're
slowly getting bored with this
repetition but that's good because
you're getting the idea
so the number parser it's the digits
parser mapped to a number remember
digits parser it's
parser that returns a string
array okay
what's the symbol parser it's just a
character that satisfies this condition
i hope you do feel the boredom we're
getting very repetitive which is great
the operation parser it's just a symbol
parser that's getting
converted into a
operation function
easy as
and we get to the evaluate function
there's a lot of code i regret but the
idea is very um the
idea is very straightforward hopefully
it tries to match
it tries to eat a number right and then
it tries to eat the opera operation then
it tries to get another number if all
successful
easy
we're going to apply the result of
operation parser which would be a
function
and apply that to two numbers
now would this work well as well
behaving software developers we have
another test suite and plenty of test
cases
now if my um
arithmetics still works
i hope this was also correct otherwise
we have a big problem but let's run this
test lead
and right oh they do work
so
you believe it we take about like 10
minutes and we created a parser from
scratch
how do you feel
okay
is the time to ask questions okay um but
hopefully everybody's getting the idea
if not the dating
well we implemented a positive
is there a question
yeah just a question uh
in terms of performance uh
how how are parts are performing
compared to rejects
that is a great question um i will get
to it later if you don't mind
sure another problem
i promise um
thank you
good question
i love it
um
well we just created a positive from
scratch right which is great
but of course in real life you possibly
don't have to
write your own parses
unless you're really obsessed which i
know some of us must be
it's so easy right you just gotta do it
developers
but sometimes we just use a library
they're you know quite well made well
maintained proven
um
we do use a library like passimon
there are terms that we use regularly to
get most jobs done so
you can see um
there is
in a sec for sequencing a few passes
there is alt or choosing from
alternatives
there is map
thing
there is many and at least to handle
repetitions
there is off and succeed they
they just succeed without consuming any
characters
there is also um
panzer dot regex
i told you i was kidding
i still need regex um
but not all parties use regex you've
seen that
but they're not mutually exclusive
and there is also skip and then um
they just conditionally capture or
ignore things they're like special maps
hope that all makes sense
um
again if you use another parser library
there are so many good ones out there
the terms would be slightly different
but the
hopefully
would be quite similar
okay um
well we've done actually uh done the
live coding but
there's something else i want to do
we're gonna go back to the url um
examples
say one day um
you know we decided that
integers are not really good
they're not really the best option for
um
book ids
have you come across this we want to
switch to
guides
but um
before i show you any code i want you to
take a few seconds think about
how you would use regex to match this
you know this guitar string
that's on
the slide
now also remember anything will be more
code than regex
because regex just you know so
dense but arguably many other options
are more clearer
and the key points of this is that i
want to show you
pauses are very easy to compose
okay
so the solution hopefully you'll see um
is quite simple in my opinion
we're going to reuse the same
um
url parser but here we're going to use
instead of book id with digits we are
going to change it we're going to use
something called good
okay so good is actually
um
a parser which i've defined here i'll
drill into it for your
benefit but also i am going to run
well-behaving software developers we
need
some um
test cases
so i'm going to run
that
of course or passes if you look at them
what is the magic
i hope this is straightforward to you i
think i like this uh good parser
it just reads out perfectly doesn't it
a parser very good
dictates that the structure of gui it's
eight hex characters followed by dash
and four followed by dash then four four
and twelve
eventually we joined them together
does this make sense
now just a quick comparison
this is what we will get with a regular
expression
noticeably it's not the regular
expression but
personally i think um i like this a bit
better
of course um i would have to show you
that hex it's a helpful function that
takes a length
and
it's the hex character parser which is
defined here
so many times enjoying the result
together as a string
but you can see we're being very
explicit here
if you're using um
pass among a good partner library
because there are more succinct ways to
do that
but here i'd like to be more explicit
let's take another look at this beauty
don't you just love that
what i forgot to show you actually um
is that i was going to implement the
calculator calculator in um
with parsimony as well let's quickly go
over that if you excuse me
um as you can see the types are quite
similar
you also have the same
converter function that converts symbols
to
two small functions
hopefully that's quite straightforward
what about number
well it's many digits remember at least
one digit
and then we join them together
what about operation well it's one of
these symbols and then we map it to a
function
i'm going to go this lower what about
arithmetic
well
it's just a sequence of number then
operation
then a number
and then take two numbers with a symbol
with the front the operation function in
between i apply
this operation function
and how do we calculate it hopefully
you've seen this a lot of times
we use the arithmetic parser to pass the
raw string
if it's successful
we return it
otherwise we'll return now
so a bit back and forth sorry about that
but hopefully this makes sense to you
this is the good that we just covered
now i know some of us will think well
that's nice you know but i can also do
that with the red x if i stretched it
just a little what's the big fast with
pizzas right
um
well there is much much more uh two
parsers um
remember it's used to make programming
languages um so it can get quite complex
but
without getting to
very advanced
case studies here is an example that you
will very possibly run into if you're
lucky
or unlucky
depending on your perspective of course
this is some sort of um
oh somebody should have told me sorry um
my fault
this is the recursive syntax that um i
personally rang into in in real life
it's possibly
kind of like json but
not quite easy it's from a time when
there's no standardization and people
just had a blast inventing their wrongs
and
you know and then a couple of weeks
later other developers had to suffer
from their genius
um
yeah perfect example of that so it's
also saved in the database as a
it's a text field so i had to
pause it and get information out of it
how's that
now this is something that would be
impossible if not very difficult
for the expressions
because it's a regular language
although i'm aware there are very
powerful regular expression engines out
there so i would rather not say never
but you know um
for my experience this would be quite
difficult
and this is where i would really need a
parser
and on that note let's bring in
baby
okay first of all
we call this data structure we call it
angle okay because of the angle brackets
now this is a valid angle
object
20y it's also a valid one
just one single
value and a string it's also
a valid angle okay
now we define the types here and i want
you to mind the recursion okay with
typescript don't you love it
so an angle
data structure is either a number
or a string
or a array of entries
or the array of entries for each entry
it's a key value pair but the value
itself can be an angle see there's a bit
of recursion okay
we also have a helper function that
converts a angle object to a javascript
object recursively okay so
this can be a bit dense
but it just goes through the whole array
and deal stands and here you can see
it's calling itself
okay so how do we get this um how do we
pass this um
you know nasty angle of uh angle string
well first we bring on an old friend
the number
i hope you are very familiar with this
now
see there are patterns
that you would come across very quickly
when you start using parsers
there is this quote thing
see i'm being very explicit i just
define a small parser for everything i'm
having a blast
and there's quoted string which
has this
parser that you know keeps taking keeps
eating
characters until another
quote is met so
a disclaimer this is a very simple
um
implementation we're not considering
escaped quotes
um or nasty things like that
and um that string will be wrapped in
two quotes
okay
i hope the syntax the fluent syntax is
uh self-explanatory
so we have quoted strings when the code
strings can be a value
or the field name okay
have a key value pair parser
which takes a child parser
and builds a key value string here you
see
we have a quoted string as the field
name
we have a dot in between then we put the
child in there
and then
with this map thing we ignore the dots
in between you see we are
we just leave it out because
we just need the key and the value but
note
the charge itself can be a angle parser
you see so there's a bit of recursion
there
now we define
the parser for an object
again we use the same pattern there's a
child we build a key value pair but then
we say we want to repeat it and there
should be at least one pair
so
we get many key value pairs
which you know that
the value of the child could itself be a
puzzle so mine's the recursion
and then we wrap them we in a couple of
uh in a pair of curly brackets not curly
sorry angle brackets and then we map it
using the helper function we had defined
above map it to a javascript object
i hope that makes sense
and we're going to bring it all together
what is an angle parser and go parser
it's a lazy puzzle okay so lazy is what
makes recursion possible
and angle as you can see
can have three alternatives remember
the types you know can be either a
number or a string let's quote it
but also it can be
recursive so angle is defined in terms
of itself
see that's also
something that that's something that's
only possible with this lazy function
okay how do we do how do we use it well
we've seen that so many times i hope
again you're getting so bored with this
um
well we use the positive deposit
and if it's successful we turn the value
otherwise
and does this work
again um i don't want you to just take
my um
words for it
oh i don't work it doesn't hurt
so all the positive cases negative cases
um they just work as expected
i'm aware this could be a bit
overwhelming if you just new to pauses
but
i hope you get the idea that you know
it's composable and you know you just
make small parts and add them together
you have a pretty big one like this one
here
in the end they just bring things
together
okay just being conscious of time um
if i have to make a recommendation um
when to use regular expressions
well
for dynamic string search accepting user
input for example you want users to give
you a regex and then
you can search in your database you know
with a regex match
but if you do that do watch out for
regular expression denial of service
there is a all os page that you can read
up on
well secondly if you want to achieve
readability
you possibly want to prioritize using
regex because well if it's simple why
bother with the new library right
so
go for it if you can achieve readability
now uh to answer the question that was
previous previously asked sorry about
the delay uh maybe for perform
well why because
some of the redex engines are there
they're really well made and they're
proven they're battle tested really
performant so
if performance is a big problem for you
then maybe you want to consider regular
expressions first however with that said
remember
there are well-made parsers out there as
well
with great performance however
you might want to assess
yourself um if it's really business
critical for you um
to have it run fast well eventually when
you don't have a choice we don't have a
choice for example some configuration
files would require you to use regex
when you don't have
you know you can't write code for it you
don't have a choice really
um
well when would i recommend that us
using for us to use parses
well obviously when something's not
simply solvable with
string comparison or regular expressions
typically when readability is hurt
which is you know why we have this talk
really um
or if you want to take things to the
next level for the full power of parsers
if you want to deal
with custom syntax
clever schema they were invented by um
you know clever developers before you
which is uh unfortunately my case in
real life but that was fun as it turned
out
or if you want to go crazy and create
your own language from
you know a mini language to a fully
fledged language actually
if you look at parsimon they actually
have a
thing that facilitates creating a
language for you think about that
or simply for fun um
parsers are amazing and they're just a
joy to work with so um
yeah try it out
well i hope you didn't fall asleep uh
during this long talk it just comes to
the time uh if you did fall asleep i
hope you slept really well
um the co examples will be on
my github account so um
just search um you know hackl w i guess
um and also please reach out anytime if
you have any questions i'll hang around
the conference
but other than that thank you very much
everyone